et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
une autre journaliste de la rédaction de
TV 78 régénéralèges bonsoir bonsoir
alors comme chaque mercredi vous nous
présentez votre chronique et du Talk ce
soir vous nous parlez de deux écoles qui
verront bientôt le jour dans les
Yvelines l'une à Mantes-la-Jolie et
l'autre à 50 ans en Yvelines tout à fait
Mathilde tout à fait et cette école
c'est l'IAG donc l'Institut des arts de
la gestion c'est une école qui propose
des formations autour du management
d'entreprise plusieurs niveaux de
diplôme sont proposés il y a un BTS il y
a aussi des Bachelor et des masters et
d'ailleurs on retrouve notamment le BTS
MCO donc management commercial
opérationnel il y a le Bachelor
Marketing Digital et communication ou
encore le master ingénieur d'affaires
alors les diplômes délivrés sont
reconnus par l'État et accessible en
formation initiale où on apprentissage
mais ce qui est intéressant notamment
c'est que cette école elle a été fondée
par deux yvelinois donc Walid youfi et
Arsène paphyla alors dans l'école elle
est basée à Clichy elle a ouvert ses
portes il y a un peu plus d'un an et ils
ont justement accueilli 80 élèves cette
année et face au succès de cette école
les deux associés prévoient d'en ouvrir
quatre autres dont une à 50 ans divine
et une à Mantes-la-Jolie alors qu'est-ce
qu'il fait la particularité de cette
école régime alors justement cette école
ce qui est intéressant également c'est
qu'elle applique la politique de
l'égalité des chances elle favorise la
diversité et l'inclusion les prix sont
également attractifs et pour entrer dans
l'école il n'y a pas de critères
spécifiques mis à part bien évidemment
le niveau bac il faut passer par des
entretiens ou justement une équipe
pédagogique se charge de de dévaluer en
fait les points forts et les points
faibles du candidat afin d'adapter au
mieux l'enseignement à l'élève la
moyenne d'âge également si on en parle
elle est assez basse elle se situe aux
alentours de 28 ans et donc du coup tout
ce qui est autour des méthodes employées
pour communiquer ou pour
partager justement les équipes ils sont
assez dans l'air du temps puisque ils
utilisent énormément les téléphones
portables et très peu les mails
puisqu'ils ont peur justement de pas
avoir de retour et puis comme on a
peut-être pu également le voir à l'écran
il y a des événements avec des remises
de prix donc tout se fait de manière
assez ludique et justement pour en
parler donc j'ai rencontré l'un des
fondateurs de l'école Walid youcy et un
étudiant également au canne aubuc je
vous propose les écouter donc on sait ce
que c'est lancé c'est quoi être étudiant
c'est quoi un étudiant
voilà en fait on est les seuls
c'est ce qui m'a apporté le plus le
contact avec les professeurs ce qu'on
partage ensemble le fait de pouvoir
communiquer avec eux n'importe quand par
SMS voilà l'accessibilité voilà leur je
le disais justement tout à l'heure
l'école semble afficher de très bons
résultats et l'objectif l'an prochain
c'est justement d'accueillir 300
étudiants et ils sont d'ailleurs sur la
bonne route puisque sur parcoursup il y
a plus de 600 étudiants qui ont déjà
indiqué l'iagées parmi leurs vœux merci
beaucoup Régine rallès et donc on suivra
avec attention l'ouverture de ces deux
nouvelles écoles dans les Yvelines
est-ce que vous savez la date ou l'année
de la voiture les deux prochaines écoles
sont prévues pour l'année 2024 donc ça
va arriver très rapidement donc ce sera
à suivre en 202